we in terms of our rule were able to
identify it as Nova choke so identify
that it was a military-grade nerve agent
we have not verified the precise source
but we provided the scientific
information to the government who have
then used the number of other sources to
piece together the conclusions that
they've come to but you have not been
able to establish at Porton Down that
this was made in Russia as I said it's
our job to provide you know their
scientific evidence that identifies what
the particular nerve agent is were
identified that it was from this family
and that it's military-grade nerve agent
but it's not our job to and see where
that actually was manufactured is it
possible to establish where these things
are manufactured it can be established
through a number of different input
sources which they which the government
has access to from our perspective
scientific evidence is only one of those
sources and it requires a number of
other things in order to verify that so
to be clear you're not able at Porton
down to say where it is from at this
stage with the work that we've done thus
far we've been able to establish that as
Nova Choe Khor from that family we are
continuing to work to help to provide
additional information that might help
us get closer to you know the question
that you asked but we haven't yet been
able to do that